ach Fabian das ist ja süß ich dachte wir
schenken uns nichts zu Weihnachten das
ist nicht für dich wir haben doch jetzt
die große Bescherung im Bundestag los
ja ich krieg wieder nix oder was nein
komm
hallo wir haben Geschenke
dabei ja wirklich Weihnachtsgeschenke
heute schon ne da habe ich ja immer
Respekt ehrlich einer der wenigen muss
man sagen
Gutschein für eine Kanzlerkandidatur von
Markus Söder
[Gelächter]
wenn Sie wollen wollen sie die einlösen
ja wie soll ich die denn einlösen ja die
können Sie einfach mal in der Fraktion
vorlegen und dann wird Friedrich Merzig
ja wenn das ein Gutschein ist
man brauchen kann sie müssen sich jetzt
für ein Geschenk
entscheiden
oder
die Sterne gesehen und dachte die kann
ich doch die kann man Weihnachten immer
brauchen wir haben Geschenke für Sie und
zwar haben wir diesen Modellbausatz
Atomkraftwerk
den können Sie zusammenbauen damit sie
am Ende des Jahres wenigstens einen
Atomkraftwerk abschalten können das
finde ich ja wunderschön wenn ich den
Nutze macht es dann auch richtig Krawumm
und Kühe fallen um
es will unbedingt den Pulli haben den
gibt es zu einem nein nein aber das ist
gut ne alle Abgeordneten tragen so was
gibt's für Geschenke und die FDP kommen
sagt ich will ja das stimmt wir haben
den großen
sozialtourismusführer wenn Sie nicht
wollen können Sie nach der AFD geben die
freuen sich über über alles steht
geschrieben Friedrich
Merzig hier lassen sie uns aus ja
diesmal ganz ehrlich ja ja
wie ist Weihnachten Geschenke braucht
die heute total Lauterbach ohne
funktioniert
tatsächlich zwei drei Corona Mutanten
damit ihn nicht langweilig wird
ja das ist schon mal sehr gut aus
also eine lehrmutante ja ja vielen Dank
wird analysiert haben sie Geschenke
verteilt aber machen sie das noch sie
könnten eine Praline haben ja
ich habe gerade keine mehr dabei
stimmt
die Regierungszeit aus den Grünen
gemacht wir machen im ZDF eine deutsche
Verfilmung übrigens vom Grinch und
wollen sie als Hauptrolle
können Sie einfach mal in die Kamera
gucken das stimmt so wie immer ja genau
ja gut es ist dann schon FSK 16 also
Kinder dürfen das nicht sehen
[Musik]
jetzt bei den Linken eigentlichen
Wunschzettel oder bekommt er jeder
ungefragt das gleiche ich habe nein
einen Wunschzettel der hat etwa 142
Punkte
wie viel glauben sie wird davon in
Erfüllung gehen anderthalb
optimistisch
wir haben noch ein Geschenk für sie
schauen Sie mal hier und zwar ist das so
ein Duftbaum
wir haben jetzt ein Weihnachtsgeschenk
für sie
haben Weihnachtsgeschenk für Sie ein
Bild von Markus Söder
eingerahmt können sich hinhängen ins
Büro oder das ist schönste Geschenke in
diesem Jahr beschert wird
haben wir gerne getan
wo ist der nächste Müller
bei der diesjährigen Weihnachtsfeier
darf da Robert Habeck eigentlich den
Weihnachtsmann spielen oder nimmt ihm
das auch noch weg
[Gelächter]
die machen wir erstens gibt es glaube
ich keine gemeinsame aller
oh mein Gott ja fabian hat doch extra so
ein FDP mottopullover angezogen also so
sieht Wolfgang Kubik in hat drei
Flaschen runter oder nein
das sind die Umfragewerte der Ampel die
durch den Kamin raus ja
okay die Hälfte ist noch draußen okay
ich habe leider jetzt sonst keine
Geschenke mehr dabei aber wenn Sie
wollen gehe ich noch zum Supermarkt und
hol was von Nestlé das können sie gerne
machen ja freuen sie sich dann nee
wollen Sie noch mehr geschenkt haben
noch mehr Geschenke
hat die Rede verpasst wegen uns
das finde ich schon sehr lustig ich
wünsche euch die letzten ja vielen
lieben Dank frohe Weihnachten
auch alle unsere Zuschauer gerne einmal
frohe Weihnachten noch frohe Weihnachten
alles Gute ja
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
hallo Leute Ich bin's der heute-show
wenn ihr mehr heißen Scheiß und liegt
dann abonniert jetzt den Kanal
was zur Hölle ist ein meme Ersteller